that resulted in a single token so solid gold magikarp is one token and in gpt2 if you ever
mentioned solid gold magikarp it thought you were saying like f you or something you got
to look this up there's like a youtube video wow dude anytime you said that it would respond it
would like curse at you it was really funny
all righty sup y'all we've got that this week in bug bounty segment uh for this week
we've got this week's this week in bug bounty segment um and what we've got on the dock at this
time is a couple updates um yes we hack uh has a new article that came out not too long ago uh recon
series six and this is entitled uh excavating hidden artifacts with wayback machine and other web archive
tools which i thought was particularly timely today because i am taking a break from hacking something
during which i just had a breakthrough using these tools um to come and tell you about these tools so
if you're not familiar with how to use way more or if you're still using gal like giveaway was uh then
you should definitely read through this article and kind of get up to date on using way more to do a
little bit more thorough investigation of the archive uh way back archive um definitely a pivotal piece
of technology for hackers also i know that they're always raising funds like they're always like please
give us money so that we can continue running this non-profit uh we need to keep this thing alive guys
because countless crits have been popped because of the wayback machine um and this article is a
really great way to sort of get up to date on it um using way more link finder gao um all sorts of
stuff so definitely check it out uh all right second update is from a hacker one disclosed report
um this one was report 2817648 and check this out guys this is a uh c plus plus uh related error where
uh sign bits derive sign traits derive bits which is a c plus plus function in the node.js core
um source code may incorrectly call throw exception on user supplied input in the background process
crashing all of node.js so um the reason this was relevant is because it actually uh you know you
can affect availability completely and you know things getting passed into these cryptographic
functions are often uh untrusted user input um so this is definitely something you want to keep an eye
out for i kind of went and checked at the um at the patch for this and essentially the patch was just
checking whether it should be able to throw or not um and so i think that there's a couple ways this
could be exploited obviously we don't want to affect availability too much but if you have some way
to fingerprint it's running on an older version of node.js then uh that could be this could be a really
cool attack and while i was researching it i actually came across this uh other exploit that was released
in that same uh may 2025 uh update which is a uh improper header block termination in lhgp
which is a piece of um node.js and this was actually found by ken ballas who uh is the guy from
hdp garden who we've talked about a couple times and essentially it allows for improper termination of
http one headers uh using slash r slash n slash r x rather than the required slash r slash n slash r slash n
um so very very interesting piece if you're interested in uh request smuggling this could be
something that you could use to potentially uh trigger some really impactful request smuggling
vulnerabilities it only got a medium and didn't get a ton of attention somehow um but i know that a lot
of you guys have a really intense http request smuggling automation out there so this would be a good one to toss on it
um all right that's all for the this week in bug bounty segment let's go back to the show
all right listen dude i've got i've got a little bit of a bone to pick with you okay um this blog post
this is how they tell me bug bounty ends is this is this fud dude is this fud or is this not fud because
i read it and i was like a little bit moved but also i'm like i don't know i've been in some meetings
with you where you felt pretty moved yeah i i i am i have moved i have moved and and and i'll be transparent
about it i mean it definitely this blog post made me realize that if i want to be on
the if i really really do want to stay ahead of the curve right by a lot then i need to start doing
you know ai agent based hacking now you need to be more enhanced by uh yeah yeah and if i want to
perform at the highest level yeah right i mean yeah i think i think that the reason why i tweeted it in
such a way where it's like you might love this or you might hate this and the reason why the blog post
even reads in like an ambiguous like just slightly ambiguous way is because i feel the same way right
i'm just i'm in the same boat as you like it's hard for me to even tell if it is fud but it's just my
honest opinion and you know maybe maybe you'll tease out yeah that haven't read the blog post give us
like the tldr of it uh i think the major points i wanted to make was people who are putting their
head in the sand and they think that ai is not going to be able to do what human hackers can do
they're wrong they're crazy i think they're like you know i've met with a lot of hackbot founders i'm
an advisor for ethiac um and so i think that these models can definitely hack and i think that the
people on the other end of the spectrum are wrong too like people who think that you know all the bug
behind hunters are going to be out of their job in six months or a year are also wrong and so the the
attack that i would you know this blog post is basically me like laying out what i think is going
to happen i guess i can give you like a two-second summary of that i basically think that the first
step in the transition is going to be called like hacker in the loop or you know basically human in the loop
but you're going to have like top hackers like you or like you know other top hackers using ai to hack
faster better smarter and also to like the the ai actually needs us to vet a lot of the what it
thinks is true positive because it just takes a lot of context and a lot of skill to know really
when something is a true positive are we going to have that context though if we're not in the weeds
like that that is one of the things that's really interesting to me like sure i can be like hey look
here's the single point of failure in the system right if you can fuzz this and get it to return a
domain that is not you know locked in this specific allow list or whatever then we've got an ssrf or
whatever right and then hand it to the ai and let it do all of the intelligent fuzzing you know and in
context aware stuff uh but that's me you know using the ai sort of as a tool and my context is greater than
the ai's context and i'm wondering if it's ever going to get to the point where my context is lower
and the ai's context is greater and that is how we hack yeah so let's just for the topic of this
conversation it might not be called this but for this conversation let's call that a black bot
hacking like a hackbot right so okay so for black box hackbots that basically are just like set to go
hack on a domain and then it comes back it's like less of a tool and more of like a fully embodied agent
right and then it comes back to you and it's like hey these are the leads i think for a lot of those
you will be able to very quickly like let's say it came back to you as a front-end guy and it's like
hey i think there's a client-side passiversal here and here's my request that's a poc and here's the
response from the here's the response that appears and here's the screenshot from the headless browser
you know is this true you know you don't think you'd be able to vet it without having to like
dig up some context yeah you could yeah yeah and so i think that that's the case there will be some
that are really complex it's like i don't know if this is working or not you know but i think that
in general those are going to be the ones that are the last to be found i think that like you know
the ai says i think xss is popping here because here's the input here's the response from the server
and here's the screenshot of the alert box and you're like well that's a pretty close shut case
right like yeah exactly and so uh yeah so i think that it's it just really varies vulnerability
to vulnerability and maybe that's why it gets so complex to like talk about is because
there are some bugs that ai will like not be able to find for 10 years maybe or 30 years right like
but there are a lot of other vulnerabilities that i think ai will be able to find and as soon as the
price point is low enough where they can spin up well i always call this the hackbot singularity but if
there's a point at which you can spin up a hackbot and it costs 10 to run but it makes you 20 in bounties
any person any same person is going to spin up as many as they can until it becomes non-profitable right
right yeah and and i mean that's the same sort of thing you see with in applying those same principles
from business with advertising and stuff like that right like if you have an advertising model that is
generating you ten dollars and costs five dollars then you're just going to keep pressing that again
yeah yeah and and um i can definitely see that happening uh i definitely agree with you that it is
more i i i think i think there will be a lot of value to these um agents that are you know black
body agents but i i i think that the the main thing that i'm convinced on right now after our
our talks and after just a couple timely interactions plus your blog post right like i i i fed something
that i was working on to uh gemini the other day and gemini like took it and like ran some tools to
parse it and like and and really did some and it was actually it's interesting that we were talking
about this off air about how you know it's a little bit less good with binary based stuff um this was one
of those cases where it was like base64 encoded binary protocol and it like still killed it and i was
like oh my gosh this is crazy yeah that's a little pro tip anytime you're dealing with something that
requires like tough accuracy i was dealing with like a neat like ai related kind of bypass i was working
on where i needed to convert the data i was trying to leak into binary but where the zero was a new line
and the one was a space and so like uh i wanted the model to basically write me a payload or like write a
little server that would like handle that well and stuff and because it was like weird syntax like you
know the ai's never been trained on binary that spaces and new lines probably yeah i i kept messing
up the format and i was like just use your code interpreter tool to convert it so then it like wrote
it in binary then converted it for me and like it's a little code interpreter and that's like a really
good pro tip like when you're dealing with stuff like you're talking about like just tell it to say
like hey you keep being inaccurate use your code interpreter tool here yeah that's that's that's a great
call yeah the code interpreter the in that specific environment did phenomenally well and i was really
uh i was kind of like jaw drop moment on that i was like i gotta start integrating this a little bit
more and then your blog post came out like the same day and i'm like it does it does take a lot of time
to write a good prompt sometimes for these like really complex vulnerabilities that we're often chasing
down as hackers but i think that if you take the time to do it and give it to smart models like the latest
gemini 25 pro or you know even oh three pro which just dropped i think that they'll often surprise you
like i think that a lot of hackers would be surprised by how much um how much it would speed them up or by
how many just good ideas it's going to have yeah and just sort of tendentially related to this and and
as a counterpoint to the whole agent thing um i've been following a little bit the hacktron ai folks
yep and uh and yeah and i think one of the founders i forget who it was i can't find the tree right now
tweeted something out like this is the future of hacking i said hacktron ai to work on this and i
went and grabbed a coffee and then i came back and i had four leads to follow right and and then you
know i went and followed those and maybe popped one of them or whatever right yeah and and i think that
is an interesting i think that's an interesting take because it's not necessarily saying that this
hacktron ai is going to just you know you're going to go grab coffee and come back i tried like here's
a report you know but it it maybe it can identify things that are higher signal sketchy than normal
programmatic tools can yeah right uh or non-ai using tools can and then you feed those leads to
you know a closer right we've talked about this a little bit on the pod before how you've got various
people in the with various skill sets in bug bounty a lot of some people are like really good lead
generators some of uh you know as far as like finding sketchy stuff some people are really good
exploitationists right or or exploitists right and and they can close close the uh you know the volume
um and i think maybe another interesting position for ai could be that it will produce really good
leads and hand it to a talented exploitist to to close the loop on yeah so i this is something i've
talked about not only do i am an advisor for one hackbot company but for the other ones when i when
i do like a call with these founders as like kind of like a vc scouting thing i will often give them
like really great advice just because i love adding value to the world and i want to see everything
improve um but i i genuinely think that how these hackbot companies handle leads is going to be huge
and i think it's because exactly what you're talking about right every lead
is a potential vuln and i think that some of the companies are over indexing on fully black box when
the reason why i mentioned in my in my blog post like the human in the loop hackbot singularity is
like a midterm spot is because of exactly what you're talking about and here's here's my exact quote
on what you're talking about i said one good hacker and a hackbot system working together will
be able to out hack almost everyone from a volume perspective and that's what i believe i mean
if i could feed you a list justin of like i don't know 10 potential xss and 10 potential cspt and 10
potential rc via command injection and you're literally just like betting them like oh yeah that
one is a bug nope that one's not yeah that one is if they're actually a decently high signal even if
it's only like 30 accurate like you would be able to make a lot of money from just like reviewing bugs
and it's almost like what we see with the um critical thinkers hackalongs right is like
um you know with the hackalongs obviously we have a ton of super talented hackers yes you know
participating in the hackalongs and in the critical thinking discord but i've been surprised by a
couple people that i that you know i would i would consider as like solid mid like intermediate hackers
right you know they really are getting really good at some stuff but are definitely fresher on the
scene right um and you know when we're hacking together i'm going down one route and then almost every
single time somebody will drop in the chat and be like hey look at this sketchy thing that i just
found yeah right so if if and i just love that right because it's like okay and then you know i'll
take that and close the loop on it and exploit it or something like that or maybe somebody else who's
better than me in the chat will do it you know and it happens almost every time we do a hack law
right and and i think that if if just applying this to ai if you can get the ai to be at at a level of
like a intermediate hacker as far as like um intuition of whether a functionality is sketchy or
not then essentially hacking becomes here's a bunch of leads from an intermediate hacker skilled hacker
now your job is to be the closer yeah i think it's much more likely that it's able to find the sketchy
leads than it is to be able to be a closer like i think i think that the closer is going to come later
i i do think that it's um big upside the big advantage it has to closing is infinite time like near
infinite time and you have infinite attempts right so if it's trying to find a very specific
payload that will bypass a specific filter it can try infinitely right assuming the the the financial
incentives align it can literally try as many times as it wants and it has and it's infinitely patient
right and so i think that really that's the advantage on it being a closer is that it can just try so
many things in such a short amount of time and you can scale it up so well but i think in general it's
going to be much better at finding the weird things those people that have taken notes really have a
massive advantage now with ai as well is like you know i have been a largely intuition based and just
reps based hacker to this point and like you know i don't have like a massive notion or whatever filled
with how i approach every single target and every vote from every live hacking event and i'm really
wishing i did now because um there are this is a massive opportunity for us to say hey you know sometimes
if you change the host header you know on a password reset you know then it's going to trigger
this thing and just give them all of the weird you've seen every single weird you've seen yeah
right and then and then hope that it has the ability to properly implement that and alert you
if something looks even remotely sketchy you know and and draw those techniques back to your mind because
we've we've talked about this time and time again how you know some bones are popular for a period and
then you stop testing those and you're like for whatever reason you maybe got shiny object syndrome and now you're
looking at for this new well i mean none of us are as disciplined as space raccoon to go through like a
spreadsheet of like all the bones that i want to check across every api endpoint right yeah exactly yeah
it's it's it's a lot man it's a lot and and uh i think ai can really help with that so yeah man for
those of you that have really good details notes on your methodology this is like a big dub for you yeah i think so
um you know i was about to say that exact thing i was like i know the guy who does that um yeah so
i i don't know that i said all of my other like major points that i wanted to make with this the
other thing that i wanted to make a point of is i just think like as kind of like proof to like call
my shot here is that i think we'll hit that human in the loop hackbot singularity by the end of the
year and there will be a company that farms you know 500 to 1000 vulnerabilities by the end of the year
and i think that that's going to be very impressive i mean expo is already like the quote unquote top
hacker in the us um and i think that it's exactly what we're talking about right i'm sure that it's
dorado and hypotermia or whatever and you know honestly the bug money platforms need to decide how
they're going to handle that because it's kind of a shared account yeah yeah that's interesting but it
is something that we need to think about well they had hacker one released something on that right like
hacker one hack bot yeah and and we like super um we super lightly covered it on the pod but uh there
is a write-up from um one of the co-founders uh mikhail on welcome hackbots how ai is shaping the future
of vulnerability discovery we'll link it link it again but yeah i mean i i think that they don't
really have any choice but to allow hackbots to yeah they need to handle it but maybe there's a separate
leaderboard for or maybe you can flag a specific account as like a hackbot account or something like
that i don't know yeah one so another thing that i want to get across with it was just positivity
amidst job loss like i think that there will be impact to hackers for sure in the long term but i
think in the medium term people can be really encouraged because one we will need human in the
loop so i do think the hackers should maybe think about what they want that to look like and maybe either
make it known on social media or reach out to these hackbot companies and be like i would i
think that the best model for this is like contract-based work rather than like hiring these
buck hunters like buck hunters love being full-time i do and so like i would love if the model is such
that i'm kind of like sponsored by ethiac or whatever and then i use that in my daily driver to both
improve their product yeah and splitting the bounties with them and you know we kind of both get the
um exposure the exposure for it i think that'd be a lot better but i mean honestly even if you're if
you're a bug bounty hunter and you are kind of worried about this maybe looking to apply to hackbot
companies is a smart decision i do think there will be a lot of money wrapped up in this for multiple
reasons one is it's just huge for humanity to like be able to secure everything in an automated fashion
two it's like a very strong nation-state related superpower like i am a believer that ai
alignment is like a really big deal and the issues that could arise from a you know somewhat um
unsafely wielded ai like if there's a you know a nation-state that we don't trust down the line
and they're using ai to do nefarious things they're going to need to they're going to want
to use it for biowarfare and they're going to want to use it for hacking and so like by
i don't know by contributing to this um effort i think that you're kind of helping humanity
in in like a really powerful way too yeah yeah yeah so anyway my i mean just take my takeaway from
your blog and and just my experiences at that point was really i need to begin the process of taking my
methodology and what i'm doing and getting it into prompts and getting it into you know something that's
raggable or or something you know um so that the ai can eventually use it once we have uh particularly
these more human in the loop micro bots sort of thing going on um so i don't know it's a little bit
of a hard thing for me because i'm like i don't really feel like taking a break from the hacking you
know to really dev on this a lot and try to get it to a point where i can do this but i'm kind of at
the point where i'm like i kind of need to do that so yeah two things two things and we're prone to
it on rabbit holes so i'm just telling you these so we don't forget to touch them yeah one is what
you're talking about right now i think that i want to talk about the hacker kind of thought um
thought process as they exploit bugs but the second thing i want to talk about with you is
tokenization i know we talked about that off air and i want to circle back to that yeah and
also i want to yeah i know what we need to do is just go in the doc go go over to the doc right now
um and write some of those down so token tokenization yeah um and what was the other one you said uh
basically the hacker's chain of thought really hacker chain of thought yeah and what is what was
yours what mine was was this other other note as well which is the reason that i got out of the
automation game yeah um you know back in like 2022 is that i don't like coding as much as i like hacking
yeah right and i found that i was spending a lot of my time coding instead of hacking yep and
that is that changed a lot recently you know like with the onset of of ai assisted coding so one of
the things i've considered is i've always that passive income piece or passively finding bugs
is has been really attractive um but it was offset by the the thing i didn't like which is
that i had to code all the time and that that offset has been erased by ai a little bit or at least
lessened so i am definitely putting more thought and consideration into going back into the automation game
whether it be hard automation or ai based automation you know um with supplementation from from code
assisting ai cool yeah yeah so the two things i want to mention one was the chain of thought from
hackers this is just um kind of a pro tip for one when you take down your notes but two i think for
these hackbot companies and three years for other hackers the ideal context for an ai model when it's
trying to exploit a cspt is your thoughts and i mean literally justin gardner's thoughts because i think
you're probably one of the foremost cspt people right and you have extremely good chain of thought in
your brain like basically your notes like like you're what why do you think cspt exists here okay
write that down okay what is the first thing you're going to attempt to check whether it exists there
okay write that down okay it failed because of this so your next payload is going to be what and why
and okay that felt okay your next payload is going to be what and why oh it worked okay cool so you
found it okay now how do we leverage this into a vulnerability okay what do you look for next in
the application okay write that down right it's like basically every thought you're having as you're
exploiting something is the ideal context for an ai language model when it's trying to exploit the exact
same thing and so i've always wanted to have like sam curry's internal i've called it internal monologue
and i even made a little app called like internal monologue capture um i think that like internal
monologue capture is actually a space for a product here if there was some yeah if there was some way
where it would like continually ask you questions or ask you to talk out loud and then it would capture
that for you um anyways i think expert expert internal monologue capture is something me and daniel
needs are talked about over a year ago when i was hanging out at his house at um rsa and i still super
key to today so dude absolutely and i think that is so hard to do it is i and and i have a lot of
experience with that because of the the um menteeing you know mentor mentee relationship where a lot of
times what i'll do sometimes with these with these mentees is i'll hack on something i'll just narrate what
i'm saying yeah and it and and my mentees are probably going to be like shut the fuck up justin because
what it actually sounds like is oh guys check this and then i just like stop talking and they're like
what do you what do you mean yeah um and i've been trying to get better at it uh and and anybody who
listens to the um hackalongs also know that i i am am very um prone to start start narrating something
and then get hijacked by like oh i need to allocate all of my mental resources to this one thing really
quickly and then and then not finish my thought but i think as you get more reps with that that is
a very like is going to be a very valuable skill uh and especially if there's some product like you're
saying that will essentially just be listening to me talk because i feel like that is the most natural way
of conveying your thoughts without friction to yourself and then convert that into a chain of
reasoning that the ai can consume to mimic your skill set in a specific area right it becomes basically
the perfect system prompt for a sub-agent that wants to exploit that same vulnerability
um yeah all right tokenization so i found that quote from kapharthi yeah so if anyone's listening
and you don't know what tokenization is you need to go look it up but i'll summarize it in like two
sentences here tokenization is the way that ai models view the world because they've been trained
on what are called tokens tokens are just strings that are associated to numbers and those floating port
numbers are like what technically the model outputs whenever it you know answers your question or
whatever it just gets converted back to the token which is back to the string which is sometimes a
full word sometimes it's only a character you can look up tokenizers to see how it works but the whole
point is tokenizers are the root of all problems so i really love this so this is this is from andre
kaparthi the father of modern llms and ai he's like very well known well regarded why can't llm spell
words tokenization why can't llm do super simple string processing tasks like reversing a string tokenization
why is why are llms worse at non-english english languages like japanese tokenization why is llm bad as
simple simple math tokenization why did gpd2 have more than necessary trouble coding in python tokenization
why did my llm abrupt abruptly halt when i sent it the string open bracket uh pipe end of text pipe
close bracket tokenization yeah like yeah why does it break whenever i ask about solid gold magikarp
which you don't know about you should go watch that youtube video it's called um gold magikarp what the
no you don't know about this no there's a thing called glitch tokens in um so glitch tokens don't really exist
anymore but basically when they were scraping the data for training data from reddit there was a few
tokens like solid gold magikarp um camel case but all with no spaces that resulted in a single token so
solid gold magikarp is one token and in gpt2 if you ever mentioned solid gold magikarp it thought you
were saying like f you or something you got to look this up there's like a youtube video wow dude any time
you said that it would respond it would like curse at you it was really funny so you got to go look this up
it's called glitch tokens and it's by computer file on youtube i'll put it in the show notes anyways
so the whole point is the our brains see the world in like we're we're somehow able to like switch between
tokens so we can see the world as words like when we read a book but we can also see the world as
characters when we need to right like special characters um and so we have like this kind of
superpower that ai doesn't have and so i was bringing this up to justin before we started the the um this episode
but i wanted to mention it because like ai doing things like http desync attacks or request smuggling
it's basically impossible due to tokenization because it can't count it doesn't really understand
how to count the number of spaces it's using and that's more of like an um arithmetic thing right
and so maybe it'll be able to figure it out if it like writes two parts of a request of a smuggled
request and then it sends both of them into python code to count the number of characters to then set the
context link but it's going to be super hard and that's an example of a vulnerability that like i
don't know if ai will solve even 10 years down the road like it's going to be a vulnerability that's
going to take a very long time like where maybe we don't even use tokenizers because there's been
some like theories that eventually we can just make each character a token and train a model that's
eventually good like that and if it viewed the world in characters i think it could potentially pull
it off but anyways um tokenization is really fascinating and interesting and i think that it
does impact the amount of vulnerabilities that can and cannot get automated at the moment i i definitely
didn't think about the fact that before you mentioned it right right before this episode that these llms
are you know thinking and living in in the token world yes from an output perspective as well as an input
yes like i knew that from an input perspective but they're also outputting tokens and if they don't have
access to you know a specific set of tokens then they can know they're not going to output or maybe if
the waiter weights are off you know they're not going to output the token that you need even though
like that was very clearly iterated as the the purpose or whatever yeah and that's where i think the
difference comes between like actual artificial intelligence and you know fabricated artificial
intelligence here um and and that is something that i i really hadn't hadn't thought about because i will
challenge i will challenge your last assumption there we also hallucinate sometimes we can't think of the
word sometimes it pops up in a different way like just because the the method of thinking i mean i don't
think that they're conscious i don't think that they have us all and we don't have to get in all that
but i do think that like just because the way in which these top models think doesn't mirror exactly how
we think i don't think that means they're not necessarily reasoning there's some really interesting
research from anthropic that shows that even before a model outputs a token it passes through different
circuits in its internal next token prediction that that mimics very similar thinking like it's it's
bouncing around on different topics that are all related to the answer even before it emits a single
token it's very very fascinating stuff yeah but um that is that is very interesting i'm definitely not
smart enough to to make an uh you know qualified association about that that's fine but what you're
talking about there about like the words it's like very fascinating there are some weird token um i've
been using cursor or sorry wow chorus chorus is like a really cool thing i used to use misty.app now i use
chorus to like ask one question to multiple models at the same time if you haven't used it it's great
but i saw someone talking about it on x and they were like you know gemini 25 pro putting in the
cheeky russian there they asked the english question and it responded in england all the
models that it was answering in parallel responded in english but gemini for two five pro threw in a
random russian word and it meant the exact same like you could understand it if you read it in english
because it was it was like um according to it was some word that you could easily tell what it should
have been in english um but it clearly just lived in the latent space of the weight at the exact same
spot and so it just picked the wrong token you know as it was passing through and so anyway stuff like
that's really interesting and i'm surprised we don't see more of it but yeah definitely definitely
interesting and i think going back to the human you know thinking versus ai thinking i definitely don't
know enough about that to make uh a conjecture but i do think that like you said it affects the
granularity of what the ais can output and i think that perhaps i'm i'm misconstruing how human neural
networks work but i think that a deeper understanding like conceptual understanding of what a character is
and what you know a character string looks like um is something that differentiates and and and as i'm
saying that i'm also realizing though that as as a beginner you think about an xss payload as an xss
payload not as an image tag and a source attribute and uh you know an invalid source attribute and an on-air
attribute and you know like so you know that's what exactly what uh you know beginner hackers are
doing when they're copying and pasting these xss payloads is like they consider that one token rather
than you know a a deeper concept or different understanding of that specific payload um i know
you've only got very interesting but i had that exact same thought i thought about how you could plug the
hole of tokenization character by character would be basically to imagine getting a whole bunch of um
conversations like simulated conversation you know how they like do um training on like back and forth
conversations imagine if there was a bunch of conversations like fake conversations between like
me and an ai or you and an ai or whatever where it was basically like quizzing it on characters so like
basically what i'm trying to say is like i wonder if we gave these top ai models a whole bunch of
content about like what a character is and how it's different than like the word like though like for
example what are the tokens in the word strawberry and it was expected to respond s t r a w b e if like
if we gave it like a trillion examples of those and threw that into the training set if it would develop
its own sense of what a character is in such a way that would improve the output i actually genuinely
think that could work um but anyways it was just a thought i had wow very interesting dude okay i like
you said i do have a hard stop but um and i might throw you to the wolves here a little bit joseph but
um i think the conversation that are the concept you gave me about um context engineering is really
interesting so i don't know if you want to talk about that you can bleep it richard can bleep it if
you don't want to uh but if you felt like it you could spend a couple minutes just sort of explaining how
difficult that problem is and how relevant is to hackers or we can cover it a different time either
way cool do you have time to say for it you're gonna drop no i'm gonna i gotta bounce okay cool
i'll stay and describe it all right you got it man all right peace peace yeah so me and justin before
we hopped on the air we're talking about what i'm calling context engineering it came out of a blog post
from harishi but also the founder of lane chain his name is harrison chase was talking about um context
engineering and how it's going to be really important i think it's like basically if you
imagine ai is like this bleeding technology and then you imagine that um the way in which you
like develop and make uh what are they called agents like this is kind of like the year of agents
is then kind of breaking technology on top of ai so like we have like agentic behavior and then on top
of that there's like sub agents and how do you hand over context from some agents to other agents
um is what harishi in this blog post he posted about um basically we may talk about this in a future
episode but harishi olical is a the best wielder of ai in my opinion and he wrote a blog post all about
how he was reversing the minified js of claude code from anthropic it's like oh hackers want to do that
all the time so i think that'd be really interesting and so i shared it in the critical thinkers chat
multiple times but um in there he he calls these intermediates but it's basically like the information
that he has that you have to hand off to get a task done and so his kind of three examples are
you have to sometimes hand off information to yourself when you go to work on the same project
on the next day right but then that's like the easiest form of handoff then the next step up is
like you're handing it off to someone who also knows the project and the company really well
and then the next step up is like handing it to someone who doesn't know well or to an ai system
that doesn't have all the context of like your company or your life or all the things that are going
on and so i think that's like pretty interesting and um it's basically how do you manage context between
agents and i think that's going to be really really key from a hackbot perspective as well right because
you may have like a core hackbot that hands off something to an agent and it doesn't pass back
enough context for the core agent to really make a true distinguish like a true validation of whether
or not what the sub agent found is like a true positive or a false positive and so anyways that's just a
cool hard problem to solve and justin thought it was really neat and i think it's something we should
all like be like leaning into and working on and looking into um super thankful for your all's time
and attention and i hope that you enjoyed the episode and we'll see you in another week
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end
y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctbb.show/discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if
you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there